- What is the most ethical career path
that you can choose?
Can it be possible that a career
in consulting or banking
is more ethical than a
career as a medical doctor?
So these are the question
that I'd like investigate with you today.
To clearly say this in the beginning,
of course, I am aware
that the proposition of this video
might be a little bit controversial.
The main purpose for me
why I created this video
is also more to just introduce you
to this line of thinking,
and hopefully inspire some of you
to think more about how
you can turn your career
into a force for good.
This is more important to me
than arguing what exactly
the most ethical career paths are.
I graduated with a Bachelor of Philosophy
in my undergrad.
I focused a lot on ethics, metaethics,
and political philosophy.
And here I thought that
this might be a great topic.
It draws from a area of philosophy
that is called the ethics of career choice
that investigates exactly these questions.
So let's start this video
with a little thought experiment.
This one got popularized by Peter Singer,
a quite well-known
contemporary philosopher.
He started his career at Oxford,
and now is a professor at Princeton,
and he describes the following scenario.
So let's imagine you're
on your way to work,
and on this way there is a pond,
And you see in the pond
that there is a kid,
and the kid is screaming for help.
The kid seems to be about to drown.
And you are a good swimmer,
you would be able to just jump in
and likely pull the kid out of the pond,
and thereby likely save that kid's life.
But would you do it?
Because if you do it, you
would come late to work.
You're wearing a fancy, tailor-made suit.
The pond looks a bit dirty,
so likely you will need
to throw away the suit.
This will have cost you
several thousand bucks.
And after all, it's not your kid.
It's not your fault that
the kid is in the pond.
You have nothing to do with it.
So think about this for yourself.
Would you jump in, save the kid,
even though this leads to damages
of your clothes of a
couple of thousand dollars?
And indeed, lots of
research has been conducted
exactly on this thought experiment,
and I think it's no surprise
that the big majority of all the people
confronted with this situation said,
"Yes, of course, I would save the kid.
Of course, I wouldn't care
if I damaged my clothe."
Many people would find it outlandish
that anyone would just
consider not doing that,
consider not saving the
kid in such a situation.
But if we hold this to be true,
how is this consistent with the fact
that every day, people die from hunger,
thirst, curable illnesses,
and other consequences of extreme poverty,
where it's just the fact
that the majority of people
don't do anything about.
And here, where it would be possible,
just with small sums,
a couple of hundred dollar,
a couple of thousand dollar,
you could save these people.
You could save these people's life.
But this is a contradiction, right,
that you are facing.
On the one hand, in this first scenario,
you would absolutely go for it, do it.
On the other scenario,
most of us apparently do
not seem to be willing
to save these people's lives,
even though we would be
able to have an impact.
So now you might ask yourself,
well, that's interesting and all,
but what the heck does this have to do
with ethics of career choice,
with whether a consulting
career is ethical or not?
And so before we dive into this,
let's pause this for a moment
and rather agree on some
terms and definitions.
Because, of course, one of
the key questions to answer
is what do we even mean by that.
What is an ethical
career choice after all?
And so for this video,
I'm adopting a consequentialist view,
which says something like
an ethical career choice
leads to a career path
that enables you to influence the world
in a positive way,
i.e., to have positive
consequences in the world.
And surely while, of course,
different types of consequences exist,
I'd say just to simplify
it a little bit it,
a good proxy would be to save lives,
or at least significantly improve
the living conditions of other people.
And so in my view,
while surely you might
come up with other aspects
that would inform this,
I'd say it's really difficult to argue
that if a career leads to
positive consequences like this,
it would not be considered
an ethical career path.
Now the next question might be
how we assess whether a career indeed has
these positive consequences or not.
And I wanna propose the standard
of counterfactual reasoning.
And what this means is that
to assess the consequences
of your actions in your career path,
you should compare the state of the world
if you would pursue the career
with the state of the world
if you would not pursue the career.
And the data of these two situations,
these two states,
this is the impact of your actions,
the impact of the career that you choose.
Now following these standards,
what are the best career
paths that you should pursue
to live an ethical life,
following this definition?
And here, one fact that I
find to be quite powerful
is that the average person
works about 80,000 hours
in his or her life, 80,000 hours.
That's a very significant
part of your life indeed,
so surely we should make sure
that these 80,000 hours matter.
And there's one quite
popular website in this field
called 80000hours.org,
that compares different career paths
exactly by these moral ethical standards.
So let's investigate different archetypes
of career paths for their ethical merits.
So let's start with
the direct benefactors.
These are careers that positively impact
other people in a positive way.
A good example would be a medical doctor.
Next are the influencers.
These are the people that motivate
and inspire other people to do good,
people who want to spread the ideas
of effective altruism,
which is the name of the movement.
And many of the ideas
I'm sharing you today
are drawn from,
and, of course, these people
can have a great impact
as they multiply the ideas,
and then many, many other people do good,
hopefully due to their instigation.
Next are researchers.
So people doing research
in relevant fields
that improve the living conditions
of many people around the world.
An example would surely be
research on renewable energies.
Last but not least, the high earners.
And these are surely people
working in consulting,
working in banking,
in professional services in general.
So people who dedicated their life
to work in careers
that enables them to earn more
than most other people around them.
And then, of course, the ideas
that these people then can use these funds
to donate to organizations
who do improve the world in a better way.
Though now while, in principle,
all of these careers can do good,
let's add the additional standard
of counterfactual reasoning.
This one says that to assess your impact,
you need to envision the world
if you would not pursue this career
with the world in which
you do pursue this career.
Let's look into the example
of a medical doctor.
At least in Western countries,
there are many more people
who'd like to become an MD
compared to the people
actually can study the subject of medicine
and have the chance to do so.
So if you are not pursuing
the career of an MD,
there will be someone
else filling your spot.
And your counterfactual contribution,
your counterfactual impact,
will only be the extent
to which you are better
than the next best candidate on the list
who would have filled your spot.
And, of course, it's
quite difficult to argue
that this impact is very
significant after all.
So let's contrast that with a career
in banking or in finance.
Because here surely the
vast majority of people,
that just a fact,
do not donate a significant
amount of their salary
every month, every year.
So if you are pursuing this career,
potentially are able to replace
the next best candidate,
who very likely will not have done that,
and you are a person who
would be willing to donate
only 10, 20% of your net income
to some charitable causes,
this data suddenly can
be quite significant,
and you will have a real impact
also by this counterfactual standard.
So this is the line of reasoning
that some people employ
to claim that a career
in investment banking
can be more ethical than, for instance,
a career as an MD.
Of course, the caveat to that
is that also as an MD,
at least the many different fields,
you will earn a significant
amount of money as well.
And then, of course,
you have the opportunity
by the fact that you become
a high earner as well
to upgrade your impact that
you can have on the world
also by this counterfactual standard.
So let's how the team from
80,000hours.org sees this,
because they really investigate
all types of different career paths.
And their summary, their main conclusion
is that they identified
these five career paths
that, from their perspective,
are the most ethical, most impactful ones.
So what you can see here,
as well as that becoming an MD
did not really make the list,
but instead, they're talking
about government and policy
in an area irrelevant to a top problem.
This will be one of
their top five choices.
Or organization building
and effective nonprofits.
So leading, building up these charities
that really do good in the world.
Third, research in relevant areas.
We just talked about this.
Fourth, applying an unusual skill
to a needed niche.
So this is to the point
of you having a very specific,
very special talent
that you can apply to really
create something good.
And then number five, earning to give.
So this is, of course,
exactly what we just talked about.
Pursuing a high-earner career indeed
can be one of the most impactful
things that you can do.
So then indeed they write about,
so what's the best way to earn to give?
So here, look for some options
where you have a great fit.
Make sure it is a high-earning path
with a good outlook.
It offers flexible career capital,
so that you're not locked in,
but can potentially also
transition in other fields.
And, of course, it doesn't cause harm.
So let's talk about this
in a moment as well,
because, of course, I know
that this is a common prejudice
against consulting or banking,
that they do cause lots of harm indeed.
So what jobs are highest-paying?
So here they talk about jobs in finance,
management, medicine,
from the perspective of being high-earner,
law, real estate, and so on.
Then they go on by talking about
what the best options overall are
to earn to give.
And as you can see here,
management consulting did make the list.
But let's now do briefly
talk about the point
of not causing harm.
And this is also a question
that they address on their site.
And just now to quote them,
they say, but don't many
high-earning jobs cause harm?
Well, of course, don't
recommend taking a job
that does a lot of harm
in order to donate the money.
In practice, most people who earn to give
work in the fields of technology
as in management, medicine, or consulting,
and we think that these positions
do a small amount of good, or are neutral.
For instance, many financial traders
make profits at the
expense of other traders,
so they are moving money around,
mostly from rich people
to other rich people.
And then, of course, there are some people
who cause harm in this industry,
but that's true of any industry.
And frankly, this is also my experience,
so I am, of course, also aware
of some of the news reports
of some consulting firms
who allegedly did things,
which really, of course, are outrageous.
And surely if you're a part
of any of these projects,
any of these schemes,
you are definitely doing harm.
While these things apparently do happen,
and, of course, everyone should work hard
in avoiding situations where
these things might arise,
I frankly think it's a bit unfair
to claim that if you work
in professional services
or in consulting,
you will regularly be exposed
or even an active part
on any of these type of situations.
So assuming you followed
the argument until here,
you know, did make the choice
to pursue a high-earning career path
with the intention to give back,
to donate some of the money,
well, the question is, well,
what shall I do with the money?
And here you might be surprised
what impact you already can have
with rather modest sums.
The different internet sites
comparing organizations and causes
that you could donate to,
one of the, as far as I know,
quite popular websites in
this area is givewell.org.
They have the list a couple of causes
which, from their perspective,
have a very high ROI.
Of course, I cannot personally endorse
any of these organizations here.
As always, please do your own research
before you decide to give money
to any of these organizations.
You could donate to malaria medicine.
So apparently for $7,
you would be able to protect
a child from malaria,
which would lead to one saved life,
for an average, every
$4,500 that you donate.
Or another example, vitamin supplements.
So for on $1, you can
deliver vitamin A supplement,
which, on average, leads to a saved life
for every $3,000 that you donate.
Or here, last on the list,
the deworming treatments.
So for about $1, you are
able to deworm a child,
cure the child from these parasites.
While these parasites might
not be life-threatening,
they significantly decrease
the quality of life of these people,
and often also significantly impact
the earnings potential of
these people in the future
in a negative way.
So these conditions go uncured,
this often means a life in extreme poverty
for the affected people,
and these people could be helped
for just $1 for deworming treatment.
But I now will, of course, be interested
in your perspective as well.
What is the most ethical career path
in your opinion?
Do you agree with the arguments
laid out in this video?
Happy to have a conversation with you
about exactly this.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
as always, please destroy the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and subscribe to stay up-to-date
on future content on this channel.
Big, big thanks to all the
members of the channel.
Thanks for your contribution.
My name is Heinrich.
I release weekly videos
on how to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So stay tuned, see you again next week,
and bye bye.